ça n'allait oui directeur de maroc
publication diplomatique bonsoir hassan
alami a bienvenue notre dans notre
émission ce soir le pjd est au pouvoir
depuis dix ans s'est littéralement
effondré lors de ces législatives a
organisé hier comment vous expliquer
cette déroute spectaculaire
c'est tout à fait c'est plus qu'un
effondrement sais c'est la descente aux
enfers franchement est ici
le sommes d'autant plus
surpris
vraiment effaré que ce parti il n'y a
pas encore il ya 24 heures était donné
comme gagnant encore une nouvelle fois
c'est à dire qu'ils allaient rien je dis
rempiler n'est ce pas il a gagné les
élections 11 il a gagné ensuite deuxième
phase de sélection 2016 et jusqu'à
l'ariège avancé qu'il n'allait pas se
laisser battre comme ça si facilement
c'est le cas de le dire bien sûr les
ceux qui perdent un accès plus jamais la
réalité mais aujourd'hui ce vote nous a
donné beaucoup d'indications et en
l'occurrence le désir d'un désir de
changement de l'internet comme on dit en
alternance en raison du mode
démocratique bien sûr parce que c'est
dans ce sens que les gens sont allés
voter il faut pas oublier qu'il ya quand
même presque 8 millions de gens qui sont
pour vous qui sont parties vocales hier
c'est à dire
car ils m'ont presque depuis lyon en
plus de plus et surtout des jeunes qui
en portait un petit peu les stockages
aux partis religieux et donc pourquoi
parce que si vous voulez une partie d'un
jeu dire de libéraux qui sont en créant
en quoi décision implicite avant je veux
dire avant le voc ont utilisé les
technologies nouvelles
ne
je veux dire l'internet et beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de technique pour
évidemment toucher les jeunes et toucher
des populations et bien sûr le pjd n'a
pas accepté n'acceptera pas du tout
jusqu'à jusqu'à nouvel ordre la
prospérité sanaa la wii de graves
irrégularités dont la distribution
d'argent à proximité des bureaux de 20
ans c'est ce qu'ils disent en tout cas
d'être certainement qu'il y a qu il ya
de l'argent mais c'est comme donc toutes
les élections et dans tous les pays on a
dit la même chose pour on allait porter
pour train pour vous et à tenir on le
dit aussi fier en france contre le
président français est évidemment on ne
peut pas contrôler ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il y avait une commission dont
pratiquement des jeux dire des gens qui
sont vérifie la régularité et la
transparence
les observateurs des droits de l'homme
des membres du parlement européen
et français en l'occurrence et qui
endeuillèrent validé et encore
aujourd'hui validé les résultats et donc
évidemment ils ont beau parler les
jambes publicité parce qu'ils ont eu
quand même gagné la mise cependant deux
fois et personne n'a contesté la nora le
résultat il est vrai que maintenant il
ya des placements sociologique si vous
voulez du lectorat marocain en ce sens
que les gens veulent bétonner un peu
plus de le dire de deux raisons de vivre
des conditions d'existence qui leur
permette d'en affronter la crise
économique
en l'occurrence covit et donc les plans
les plans qui sont proposés par les
partis libéraux sont des plantes qui
évidemment inscrivent s'il voulait
l'économie et les besoins essentiels des
populations dans leurs priorités nous
affrontons aujourd'hui le coc vide mais
nous sommes aussi sur le poisson si vous
voulez de m j'allais dire en oeuvre un
plan ambitieux qui s'appelle le nouveau
modèle de développement
rapidement sa maladie dernière question
le roi mohamed 6 1 devrait les y ait
dans les prochains jours la personnalité
a chargé de former
voilà on a perdu à ça allawi doudou
l'arrêt brutal effectivement de
l'interview voilà c'était en tout cas ce
n'est la wii directeur de la publication
maroc diplomatique merci à lui